mike welcome it's good to see you i'm
excited for this conversation thank you
so much i'm so happy to be here
so most of us have this mental model in
biology
that dna is a property of every
living thing that it is kind of the
software
that builds the hardware of our body
that's how a lot of us think about this
that model leaves too many deep
mysteries
can you share with us some of those
mysteries and also
what tadpoles have to do with it sure
um yeah i'd like to give you another
perspective on this problem so
one of the things that dna does is
specify the hardware of each cell
so the dna tells every cell what
proteins
it's supposed to have and so when you
have tadpoles for example
you see the kind of thing that most
people think
is a sort of a progressive unrolling of
the genome specific genes turned on and
off
and a tadpole as it becomes a frog has
to rearrange its face
so the eyes the nostrils the jaws
everything has to move and one way to
think about it
used to be that well you have a sort of
hard-wired set of movements where
all of these things move around and then
you get your frog actually a few years
ago we found a pretty amazing phenomenon
which is that
if you make so-called picasso frogs so
these are tadpoles where
the jaws might be off to the side the
eyes are up here you know the nostrils
are moved so
everything is shifted these temples make
largely normal frog faces now this is
amazing because
all of the organs start off in abnormal
positions
and yet they still end up making a
pretty good frog face and so
what it turns out is that this system
like many living systems
is not a hardwired set of movements but
actually
works to reduce the error between what's
going on now and what it knows is a
correct frog face configuration
this kind of decision making that
involves flexible
responses to new circumstances in other
contexts we would call this intelligence
and so what we need to understand now is
not only
the mechanisms by which these cells
execute their movements and gene
expression and so on
but we really have to understand the
information flow
how do these cells cooperate with each
other to build something large
and to stop building when that specific
structure is uh is created
and these kinds of computations not just
the mechanisms but the computations
are of anatomical control for the future
of biology
and so i guess the traditional model is
that somehow
cells are sending biochemical signals to
each other that
allow development to happen you know the
smart way but but you think
there is something else at work what is
that well cells certainly do communicate
biochemically and via physical forces
but there's something else that's going
on that's extremely interesting
and that is that uh it's it's it's
basically called bioelectricity
non-neural bioelectricity
so it turns out that all cells not just
nerves but all cells in your body
communicate with each other using
electrical signals and what you're
seeing here
is a time lapse video that for the first
time we are now
able to eavesdrop on all of the
electrical conversations that the cells
are having to with each other
so think about this we're we're now
watching this is an early frog embryo
this is about eight hours to ten hours
of development
and the colors uh are showing you actual
electrical state
that allows you to see all of the
electrical software that's running on
the genome-defined
uh cellular hardware and so these cells
are are just
basically communicating with each other
who's going to be head who's going to be
tail who's going to be left and right
and make
eyes and brain and so on and so it is
this software that allows these
living systems to achieve specific goals
goals such as building an embryo
or regenerating a limb for animals that
do this
and uh the ability to to uh
see these electrical conversations gives
us some really remarkable uh
opportunities to target or to rewrite
the goals towards which these living
systems are operating
okay so let me this is pretty radical
let me see if i understand this what
what you're saying is that
when an organism starts to develop
as soon as the cell divides electrical
signals
are shared between them but as as you
get to 100 a few hundred cells
that somehow these signals end up
forming a kind of a essentially like a
computer program
a program that somehow includes
all the information needed to tell that
organism
what its destiny is is that the right
way to think about it
uh yes quite uh basically what happens
is that these cells by
by forming electrical networks much like
networks in the brain
they they form electrical networks and
these networks process information
including
pattern memories uh they they include
representation
of large scale anatomical structures
where various organs will go
what the different axes of the animal
front and back head and tail are going
to be
and these are literally held in the
electrical circuits across
large tissues in the same way that
uh that brains hold uh you know other
kinds of memories and learning
so is this the right way to think about
it because it this this seems to me
such a big shift i mean when i first got
a computer
um i was in awe of the people who could
kind of programming
do do so-called machine code like the
direct programming of individual
bits in the in the computer that was
impossible for most mortals to have a
chance of controlling that computer
you'd have to
program in a language which which was a
ho
you know just a fastly simpler way of
making big picture things happen and if
i understand you're right what you're
saying is that most of biology today has
sort of taken place
trying to do the equivalent of machine
code programming of like understanding
the biochemical signals between
individual cells
when wait a sec holy crap there's this
language going on this electrical
language which if you could understand
that
that that would give us a completely
different set of insights into how
organisms are development is that
metaphor basically right
yeah this is exactly right so if you
think about the way programming was done
in the 40s in order to
get your computer to do something
different you would physically have to
shift the wires around so you would have
to go in there and rewire the hardware
you would have to interact
with the hardware directly and all of
your
strategies for manipulating that machine
would be at the level of the hardware
the reason we have this now amazing
technology revolution information
sciences and so on is because computer
science moved from a focus
on the hardware onto understanding that
if your hardware is good enough and i'm
going to tell you that biological
hardware is absolutely good enough
then you can interact with your system
not by
tweaking or rewiring the hardware but
actually you can take a step back
and give it stimuli or inputs the way
that you would give to a reprogrammable
computer
and uh cause uh caused the the cellular
network to do something completely
different than it would otherwise have
done
so this bioelectric the ability to see
these bioelectrical signals
is giving us an entry point directly
into the software that
guides large-scale anatomy which is a
very different approach to
uh to medicine than to rewiring specific
pathways inside of every cell
and so many ways this is the amazingness
of your work is that you're starting to
crack the code
of these electrical signals and you've
got an amazing demonstration of this
in these flat ones tell us tell us
what's going on here
so this is uh this is a creature known
as a planarian they're flatworms
they're actually quite a complex
creature they have a true brain
lots of different organs and so on and
the amazing thing about these planaria
is that they are highly highly
regenerative so if you cut it into
into pieces in fact over 200 pieces
every piece will rebuild exactly what's
needed to make a perfect little worm
so think about that this is a system
where every single piece
knows exactly what a correct planarian
looks like and
builds uh the right organs in the right
places and then stops
and that's one of the most amazing
things about regeneration so what we
discovered is that if you
cut it into three pieces and amputate
the head and the tail and you just take
this middle
fragment which is what you see here uh
amazingly there is a
an electrical gradient head to tail
that's generated that tells the piece
where the the heads and the tails go and
in fact how many heads or tails you're
supposed to have
so what we learned to do is to
manipulate this uh electrical gradient
and the important thing is that we don't
apply electricity what we do instead
was we turn on and off the little
transistors they're actually ion channel
proteins
that every cell natively uses to set up
this electrical state and so now we have
ways to turn them on and off
and when you do this one of the things
you can do is you can shift
that circuit to a state that says no
build two heads or in fact build no
heads and what you're seeing here
are real uh worms that have either two
or no heads
that result from this because that
electrical map is what the cells are
using to decide
what to do and so what you're seeing
here are live
two-headed worms and having generated
these we did
we did a completely crazy experiment you
take one of these two-headed worms
and you chop off both heads and you
leave just a normal middle fragment
now keep in mind these animals have not
been genomically edited there's
absolutely nothing different about their
genomes their genomic sequence is
completely wild type
so you amputate the heads uh you've got
a nice normal
fragment and then you ask in plain water
what is it going to do and of course
the standard paradigm would say well if
you've gotten rid of this ectopic the
extra tissue
the genome is is not edited so it should
make a perfectly normal worm
and the amazing thing is that that is
not what happens these worms
when cut again and again in the future
in plain water they continue to
regenerate as two-headed
think about this the pattern memory to
which
these animals will regenerate after
damage
has been permanently rewritten and in
fact we can now write it back and get
to send them back to being one headed
without any genomic editing
so this right here is telling you that
the information structure that tells
these worms how many heads
they're supposed to have is not directly
in the genome it is in this
additional bioelectric layer probably
many other things are as well
and we now have the ability to rewrite
it and that of course
is the key definition of memory it has
to be stable long term stable
and it has to be rewritable and we're
now beginning to crack
this morphogenetic code to ask
how is it that these tissues store a map
of what to do and how we can go in
and rewrite that map to new outcomes
i mean that seems incredibly compelling
evidence that
that there's you know that dna
is uh is just not controlling the actual
final shape
of of these organisms that there's this
whole other thing got
going on and uh boy if you could crack
that code
um what what else could that lead to by
the way just look at these ones what is
what is life like for a two-headed
flatworm i mean it seems like it's kind
of a trade-off like the good news is you
have this amazing
three-dimensional view of the world but
the bad news is
you have to poop through both of your
mouths
so the worms have these little tubes
called pharynxes and they ext
the tubes are sort of in the middle of
the body and they excrete through that
um these animals are perfectly viable
they're completely um happy i think
uh the problem however is that the two
heads don't cooperate all that well and
so they don't really eat very well um
but if you manage to feed them by hand
they will go on forever and in fact you
should know these worms are basically
immortal
so these worms because they are so
highly regenerative
uh they have no age limit and they're
telling us that
if we crack the secret of regeneration
which is not only growing new cells but
knowing when to stop you see this is
this is absolutely crucial
if you if you can continue to exert this
uh really profound control
over the three-dimensional structures
that the cells are working towards
you could defeat aging as well as uh
traumatic injury and things like this
so so one thing to keep in mind is that
this ability to rewrite
the large-scale anatomical structure of
the body is not just some weird
planarian trick it's not just something
that's
uh that works in in flatworms so what
you're seeing here is a tadpole with an
eye and a gut and what we've done is
we've turned on
uh very specific ion channels so we
basically just
manipulated these little electrical
transistors that are inside of cells
and we've imposed a state on some of
these gut cells
that's normally associated with building
an eye and as a result what the cells do
is
they build an eye these eyes are
complete they have uh optic nerve lens
all the same
uh retina all the same stuff that an eye
is supposed to have they can see by the
way out of these eyes
and what you're seeing here is that by
triggering uh eye
building subroutines in the
physiological software of the body
you can very very uh easily tell it to
build a complex organ now this is
important for biomedicine because
we don't know how to micromanage the
construction of an eye i think it's
going to be a really long time
before we can we can really bottom up
build things like eyes or hands and so
on
but we don't need to because the body
already knows how to do it and there are
these
these subroutines that can be triggered
by specific electrical patterns that we
can find and this is
this is what we call cracking the
bioelectric code we can make eyes we can
make extra limbs here's one of our
five-legged tadpoles
we can make extra hearts we're starting
to crack the code to understand
where are the subroutines in this
software that we can trigger
and build these complex organs long
before we actually know how to
micromanage the process at the cellular
level so
as you've started to get uh to learn
this
electrical layer and what it can do
you've been able to
create is it fair to say it's almost
like a new a novel life
form called a xenobot talk to me about
xenobots
right so so this if you if you think
about this this leads to a really
strange prediction
if the cells are really willing to build
towards a specific
map we could we could take uh
genetically unaltered
cells and what you're seeing here is
cells taken out of a frog body
they've coalesced in a way that asks
them to re-envision their
multicellularity
and what you see here is that when
liberated from the rest of the body of
the animal
they make these tiny little novel bodies
that are in in terms of behavior you can
see they can move they can run a maze
they're completely different from from
frogs or tadpoles
frog cells when asked to uh
re re-envision what kind of body they
want to make do something incredibly
interesting
they use uh the the hardware that uh
that their genetics gives them for
example these little hairs these little
cilia that uh that are normally used to
redistribute mucus on the outside of a
frog those are genetically specified
but what these these uh creatures did
because the cells are able to form
um novel novel kinds of bodies they have
figured out how to use these
these little cilia to instead row
against the water and now
uh have locomotion so not only can they
move around
but they can uh and here here what
you're seeing is that these cells are
coalescing together now they're starting
to have conversations about what they're
going to do
you can see here the flashes are uh
these these exchanges of information
keep in mind this is just skin there is
no nervous system
um there is no brain this is just skin
this is skin that has learned to make a
new body
and to explore its environment and move
around and
they they have spontaneous behaviors you
can see here where it's
swimming down this maze at this point it
decides to turn around and go back where
it came from so it has its own
behavior and this is this is a
remarkable model system for several
reasons first of all
it shows us the amazing plasticity of
cells
that are genetically wild type there's
no genetic editing here these are cells
that are
really um prone to making some sort of
functional body
the second thing and this was this was
done in collaboration with josh
baumgardt's lab at uvm
they uh modeled the um uh
the structure of these things and
evolved it in a virtual world
so this is literally on a computer they
modeled it on a computer so this is
literally
the only organism that i know of on the
face of this planet
whose evolution took place not in the
biosphere of the earth but inside
a computer so the individual cells have
an evolutionary history but this
organism has never existed before
and it was evolved in this virtual world
and then we went ahead and made it um in
the lab and you can see this amazing
plasticity so
this is this is um not only for making
useful machines you can imagine
uh now programming these two go out into
the environment and collect toxins
and clean up or you can imagine ones
made out of human cells that would go
through your body and collect cancer
cells or
uh reshape arthritic joints you know
deliver
uh pro-regenerative compounds all kinds
of things but not only these useful
applications
this is an amazing sandbox for learning
to communicate
morphogenetic signals to cell
collectives so once we crack this once
we understand
how these cells decide what to do and
then we're going to of course learn to
rewrite that information
the next steps are a a great um
great improvements in regenerative
medicine because we will then be able to
tell cells to build
healthy organs and so this is now a
really
critical opportunity to learn to
communicate with cell groups not to
micromanage them not to force the
hardware
but to communicate and rewrite the goals
that these cells are trying to
accomplish
well it's it's mind-boggling stuff um
finally
mike give us just one other story about
medicine that might be to come as you as
you
develop this understanding of how this
bioelectric
layer works yeah this is incredibly
exciting because if you think about it
most of the problems of biomedicine so
birth defects
degenerative disease aging traumatic
injury even cancer
all boil down to one thing cells are not
building what you would like them to
build
and so if we understood how to
communicate with these uh collectives
and and really um rewrite their their
their target morphologies
we would be able to normalize tumors we
would be able to repair
birth defects induce regeneration of
limbs and other organs
and these are things we have already
done uh in in frog models and so now the
next uh really exciting step
is to uh to take this into into
mammalian cells
and to really turn this into the next
generation of regenerative medicine
where we learn to uh to to address
all of these biomedical needs by
communicating with the cell collectives
and rewriting their bioelectric pattern
memories
and the final thing i'd like to say is
that the importance of this field is not
only for biomedicine you see this as i
started out by saying
this ability of cells in novel
environments to build
all kinds of things besides what their
genome tells them
is an example of intelligence and
biology has been intelligently solving
problems long before brains came on the
scene
and so this is also the beginnings of a
new inspiration for machine learning
that mimics the artificial intelligence
of body cells not just brains
for applications in computer
intelligence
mike levin thank you for your uh
extraordinary work and for
sharing it so compellingly with us thank
you thank you so much thank you chris
you